I was in the Solomon Islands on a
National Geographic expedition we were
working in the shallow reef and we had a
big blue light that we were filming
florescent corals one of the safety
divers Brendan Phillips came up to me
and was just started tugging on my
camera and basically just gave me the
message you know follow me so I turn off
my lights I followed him for several
hundred meters in the dark suddenly I
see why he pulled me there there are
literally thousands of blue blinking
bioluminescent lights and they were
coming together and they were joining
and it would be circles of them and it
was almost like a a blue bioluminescent
brick road just descending down the reef
making all these shapes it's the closest
thing I've ever had to an avatar moment
this is the largest aggregation of
flashlight fish that that I believe
humans have ever come across these
animals that they don't even come out
when the moon is out they're so
sensitive to light because they're so
easily gobbled up by a bigger predator
so it has this sub ocular bioluminescent
organ under its eye and it grows like a
garden these bioluminescent bacteria and
it grows them in these tubes and it even
projects the light outward it's even
grown this vasculature to feed to pump
oxygen to keep these bioluminescent
bacteria glowing bright one thing that
they do is when they're actually eating
they will keep their light on so they
can see the food so they're very visual
creatures and they're using their light
to feed but when they're not feeding
they're using their life to be able to
move in a school a quarter of all fish
species sometime in their life they
school and there's all kinds of benefits
to schooling the safety in numbers and
it makes it harder for a predator to
really Zone in on one specific fish
what's unique about these animals is the
relationship they have with this
bioluminescent bacteria that they
harvest in their eye only nine species
have this ability we do know that they
do something called a blink and run when
they want to evade a predator they will
start swimming in one direction blink
and then immediately turn in the other
direction so a predator trying to follow
in the bark will will lose it recording
this and proving this opens up the
possibility that the deep sea is filled
with billions of bioluminescent
schooling fish and us humans have just
seen this yet because we're not in the
deep sea with all our lights off
[Music]
[Music]